this he does okay he's one he's like you
said he's one of those guys there's this
versatile man and Miami Heat he has the
ball in his hand a lot so this is not
foreign to him he's used to this so I
look forward to he has speedy ass
quickness but he's he's gone out naked
knocking down that shines he gonna play
it cool yes knock it down there shot I
told him don't play what do you have to
knock down this time and remember this
for winners
pigma karl-anthony towns and kristaps
porzingis so the first one nada bio
against different Canada we need not go
play around though
go BAM yeah this two-month answer too
much times
don't move back clean go see you being a
little too cool it's about not being
cool now he got a shooter and he's not a
shooter he knocked out on former champ
and he did it casually yeah but he's
been here before look at this but the
first buoy see why dinner had eyes and
look at that you know what coach holding
him back
go slow and hold it BAM back he's gonna
go in and ask for a raise he's coming
out of the break soon threes now this is
like what I learn here Oh Duncan
Robinson by oh there we have to again
see outcomes I guess you're gonna ride
the horse he got the name damn from his
mom who said he was as strong as banned
banned from the Flintstone cartoon and
he's proven to being very good player
kind of year
a great year pathos shock of attack
Toronto Most Improved Player last year
knock this down BAM suck it down Oh see
[Applause]
to be fair to be fair ready what on TNT
Tuesday show I pay all my goodness
Wow like it had I'm telling you he's
gonna tell spoke that he needs more
plays drawn up yo Reggie I don't know
about you Wheeling heading into the
contest just feeling excited you know I
have an opportunity to come out here and
just make it a good one I would imagine
you want to keep Dwyane Wade proud he's
a perennial all-star this is the first
time he's sitting and watching from the
sidelines yeah
trying to make New Wave proud here in
this city mess on the try to Britney's
tips cool alright let's get it going
alright Kristen Ledlow the bigger guy is
one all match up so far which we were
talking about before Hannah's we've got
Sabonis let's do this okay mister sub
own and keep like Lisa do for you Dennis
let's go BAM
oh he's mine now babe is flying down the
role please come in bang through
let's go BAM let's go better come down
to the shop make the shot BAM there's
gonna come down to the shop good this is
the bonus is in the right position take
your job
you don't
[Applause]
listen that's what we do I feel things
are shaping up tonight yeah I feel
things are shaking three-point
competition and the slam dunk it was all
going to come down off the shot they
both were perfect on their path but here
it is yes sir
here follow your mama call them BAM I'm
a calling me Bam Bam Bam
[Music]
bringing it back to south be a minute
listening when the Miami Heat get it to
all-star weekend here normally bring
home a trophy I'm just gonna throw it
out there the last Miami winner to Wayne
Wayne ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Taco Bell president and global
chief operating officer Mike grams who's
on hand to present the 2020 Taco Bell
Skills Challenge Trophy to our winner
BAM Adebayo
ladies and gentlemen Kristen Ledlow
congratulations BAM what a weekend it's
been for you already you said you
weren't gonna let Dwyane Wade down you
wanted to represent not only for Miami
but for him here in Chicago but he did
mention this says a little bit about the
direction the game is headed that we've
got a big taking home the trophy yeah
you know premier big but uh sky's the
limit for players man you know the
development and the way the game is
going man and uh got me a trophy man
he's going next
he's going to a special one I'm gonna
give it to my mom man congratulations
give it up one more time for your 2020
Taco Bell Skills Challenge champion BAM
Adebayo keep more keep more
hey listen they all so proud of you boys
[Applause]
you had to go ahead you gotta go forth
from Chicago you're watching the 20/20
State Farm all-star Saturday night
[Music]